let's get to some audience questions
good one from Alex today hey David what
belief are you most embarrassed to have
held in the past I used to be a pretty
big believer in supply-side economics oh
I used to believe when I first learned
about economics in high school and
before I had a more nuanced
understanding and new alternative
economic theories and you more about
behavioral economics etc I kind of fell
for supply-side economics hook line and
sinker
I fell for rational the net rational
market hypothesis that markets are
perfectly rational I basically fell for
the entire thing and knowing what I know
now even though I was only 16 at the
time it's still a little embarrassing
for me to to remember having believed
that stuff but it's okay I was only 16
right I mean it's hey at least I was
even learning about economics yeah
around though I don't own the rights
eventually I feel like I figured out the
the the truth about that I used to think
this is not so much an embarrassment but
I kind of cringe when I think back I
moved to the United States from
Argentina when I was five years old and
I moved to the US knowing only two words
in English the words were stopped and
blue and in fact on the ride home from
the airport at the first stop sign that
I saw I immediately said stop and I
thought this is gonna be great of course
it just so happened that half of the
words that I was familiar with I was
presented with on the road and it wasn't
quite so easy but in any case when I was
in first grade some students started
swearing and for the longest time I
would hear students say what I thought
was missus whatever such-and-such said
Square and what they were saying was
such-and-such said I swear
so I had about six months where I
thought Square was a bad word like
square is one of the seven dirty words
you can't say it until eventually I said
to a friend are we're not supposed to
say Square and she says no no no she
said I swear I swear and then I figured
out oh and it was actually the f-bombs
yeah then I figured out oh it's actually
Square is an okay word just kind of
psychic I crazy talked about it and
first-grade is also the time where you
learn about shapes too so I could see
how that confusion yeah like what was so
vulgar about squares that you weren't
allowed to talk
about them I mean it's a type of
rectangle why would it be so offensive
equal sides maybe yeah equal sides was
apparently something that the teacher
didn't really want us talking about and
then the other thing I some point when I
was younger I kind of had this idea that
by the time you're about twenty-five
years old an adult you have everything
kind of figured out like you just have
the world figured out and you're
completely well-adjusted and
self-realized and self actualized and
then there's no more sort of like
uncertainties and it's not that I'm
embarrassed that I believe that but I do
realize how silly it is and now I you
know I know people who are in their 40s
50 60 70s and they say you never really
have it all figured out you get more
comfortable with certain areas of life
and the world but you never actually get
to I've arrived I now have it figured
out your thing that's not true no yeah I
mean I know Pat's waiting for next year
to believe that he now has it all
figured out but those are the things I
think of and it's not so much that
they're embarrassing but just that they
kind of expose naivete in some way hate
to think that reindeer were mythical
creatures oh that like a unicorn yeah
like a unicorn because of course you
know you grow up at least in my
tradition with it from a Christian
background showing in the story of Santa
coming to your house and you know he has
elfs and the reindeer so when I found
out that spoiler alert
Santa's not true yeah I immediately
thought that reindeer weren't true as
well that's pretty it wasn't until I was
like 18 that I find out that they're
actually a thing
yes reindeer not like unicorns that
doesn't interest you I the upside is
you'll never hear about the keurig
scandal again after telling us you used
to think reindeer weren't uh weren't
real I actually never believed in any of
the Christmas stuff at all I never
believed in Santa because I was raised
Jewish secular Jewish and it's funny
because I I was aware of six seven and
eight year old classmates who believed
in that and I would always just say well
how do you believe with that how do you
I would just I didn't know that it was
impolite to the kind of spoil it so I
would say Santa's not real what are you
talking about Wow okay yeah because I
mean once kids find out they tell
everyone in the class yeah yeah yeah and
I don't remember offending anybody in
particular but I remember being very
confused like why do these kids believe
in this stuff I don't I don't really get
it